et tant entendu que lorsque la retraite
a été fixée à 65 ans la moyenne de vie
des travailleurs était de 55 et c'est
comme ça que les choses se sont faites
en arrachant à la société dirigeante les
concessions qu'elle refusait
les 35 heures
la semaine de travail à 35 heures
je voudrais rappeler aux socialistes qui
sont ici
apprendre peut-être à ceux qui ne le
sont pas
les socialistes
que c'est toute la bataille menée depuis
le 19e siècle
qui se trouve ainsi résumé
la bataille pour le temps de vivre la
conquête du temps de vie mais qu'est-ce
que c'est que la vie qu'est-ce que
c'était que la vie pour un prolétaire au
milieu du 19e siècle c'était à 7 ou 8
ans le travail pour le compte des autres
c'était le travail jusqu'à la mort et
sans repos il n'y avait pas de retraite
à la fin de la vie il n'y avait pas
d'arrêt de vacances ou de congés payés
en cours d'année il n'y avait pas de
week-end il n'y avait pas de journée de
repos peut-être parfois le dimanche
matin pour la messe
c'est tout
et celui qui est né ses prolétaire
il était voué jusqu'à la mort à
connaître et à subir cet état sans
aucune chance d'y échapper non seulement
pour lui-même mais aussi pour 16 ans
et le combat des socialistes depuis le
premier jour ça a été de conquérir un
peu de temps de vivre
la retraite est entendu que lorsque la
retraite a été fixée à 65 ans la moyenne
de vie des travailleurs était de 55
c'est comme ça que les choses se sont
faites en arrachant à la société
dirigeante les concessions qu'elles
refusaient j'ai rappelé dans cette salle
lors d'une autre rassemblement dont je
me souviens fort bien de quelle façon il
a fait il avait fallu que les socialiste
et que les gens disent les démocrates de
cette époque
homme et femme de cœur
se battent contre la société dirigeante
pour obtenir que les enfants de moins de
10 ans c'est de travailler 14 heures par
jour dans le fond de la mine quelquefois
c'est un rapport soumis à l'Académie des
Sciences en 1847 quelquefois les
poignées attachées aux machines
mais quand on disait cela nous la gauche
qu'est-ce que nous répondait la droite
mais vous avez peut-être raison cette
humain nous comprenons fort bien mais le
moment n'est pas venu
qu'est-ce que vous voulez ces enfants
c'est vrai leur sort est assez pénible
bien que c'est une circulaire une
directive du ministre du Commerce de
l'époque bien que habitué des jeunes
enfants à cette souplesse que de voir
aller là où un homme mûr ne pourrait pas
dans le fond de la Bible dans des
galeries un peu étroites cela leur donne
des qualités de travail qui à l'âge de
30 ans sont tout à fait remarquables
bien entendu ils avaient les os brisés
par le travail que l'on exigeait d'eux
mais que ce que vous voulez disait ce
genre de droite il faut le faire mais
plus tard
vous n'avez pas le droit de laisser la
France
supporter la concurrence extérieure
il faut gagner la bataille industrielle
chaque fois ça a été comme ça lorsque
les femmes en 1874 ont pu obtenir de
rester plus de 3 jours absente de
l'établi lorsqu'il est venait d'avoir un
enfant c'était la même chose lorsqu'on a
voulu en 1880 on célèbre le centenaire
cette année celui de Jules Ferry il
était parlementaire des Vosges
précisément lorsque les enfants du
peuple ont été admis à l'enseignement
l'enseignement primaire simplement
l'enseignement primaire gratuit on a dit
mais quoi alors c'est la production
française qui va être privé de tous ses
bras peut-être le fallait-il
mais on devait attendre nous ne sommes
pas en état de supporter la concurrence
internationale et quand la semaine de
travail
est passé à 60 heures
même des bas
quand c'est passé à 48 heures au
lendemain de la guerre de 14-18 même
débat et lorsque Léon Blum et le
gouvernement du Front populaire en 1936
sont décidés les 40 heures la même
discussion que celle d'aujourd'hui a eu
lieu
comme si
comme si nous n'en n’étions pas à la
troisième certains d'autres diraient
même quatrième révolution industrielle
comme si l'avènement et la
transformation de la machine ce qu'on
appelle en terme savant la mutation
technologique n'avait pas créé des
conditions nouvelles du travail
quoi tous ces chômeurs
tandis que les autres travailleront 9
heures par jour
tandis que ils seront soumis à des
cadences et à une organisation du
travail écrasante d'autres n'auront rien
seront ceux que je décrivais dans les
files d'attente du chômage
quoi au moment même où la robotique
l'informatique ou la machine substituée
non seulement aux muscles mais aussi au
jugement et à la mémoire de l'homme est
en mesure de produire de produire de
produire quoi ce serait l'homme qui
serait victime de cette transformation
alors qu'en vérité la machine a toujours
été considérée par ceux qui ont pensé la
société comme un moyen de se substituer
à la peine et à la fatigue c'est
finalement la machine qui commande dans
le circuit capitaliste et l'homme qui
doit apporter ou son travail
ou son chômage c'est la machine qui
commande quoi la société présente et la
société dirigeante représentée par
l'actuel candidat sortant
en France mais tant d'autres dans les
pays industriels d'alentour des
États-Unis d'Amérique n'ont pas été
capables de penser à l'échéance d'une
machine capable de produire et le sort
des hommes des travailleurs qu'elle
serait-il et à mesure que les mutations
technologiques se sont produites
naturellement à mesure le temps de
travail et la cadence du travail des
hommes c'est modifié lorsque je propose
35 heures de travail par semaine je ne
propose pas 35 heures de production par
semaine je veux que les hommes
s'arrêtent au bout de 35 heures avec un
salaire égal à celui qu'ils avaient mais
je veux que les machines continuent de
tourner ce qui veut dire qu'il faudra
qu'il faudra embaucher des équipes
nouvelles dans un temps raisonnable sans
que l'on profite de mon raisonnement
pour dire et bien elles vont rouler 24
heures sur 24 ce qui serait une nouvelle
façon de tourner le problème
de manquer aux droits social
[Musique]